as ambulances lined up to take injured
people to Egypt for some Palestinians
the opening of the RAF Crossing was an
opportunity to return home to Gaza for
many it had been a long wait Jamal yusf
Atia lives in Algeria he spent 43 days
on the Egyptian side of the Border
waiting to get into
Gaza people are leaving and we are
returning to the war and despite
everything we are returning because this
is our country it is logical one only
has his country this may be only a short
break from Israel's bombardment with
little news of loved ones the 4day
ceasefire is an opportunity for family
reunions some of my family members moved
to Central Gaza to an area called
aler I'm going home now and my family
doesn't even know I'm coming
have no contact with
them we were stuck for 46 days on the
Egyptian side thank God we enter today
our joy is Indescribable we miss our
family and loved ones we have children
in Gaza now that we have returned God
willing we will be reunited and the war
will
end but there is no guarantee that the
war is about to end Israel says it will
resume its attacks until Hamas is
defeated
honestly I don't think the truce will
last what I ask of the Palestinian
people is to support the resistance
Hamas because unfortunately it needs
support during these times the
resistance was left alone and it is
achieving great
victories in the meantime exhausted and
traumatized Palestinians will cherish
these moments of
calm despite Israel's warning that this
is only a posst and not the end of the
war these Palestinians have chosen to
come back to Gaza they may not have
homes to return to but they say they may
find some comfort in being together with
their families yid Al jazer Rafa in the
southern Gaza
Strip make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer